so I mean the title of the video no
jumper poster says salesman accidentally
calls his black neighbor the n-word I
mean it's a good time first time I see
this I go how do you accidentally call a
black guy at the end where I don't
understand this is what happens he just
Rings the ring doorbell here we go
[Music]
hey how you doing hey sorry to bother
you I'm Fernando I work with pick energy
we're a few doors down we're in 1845.
okay so we do solar around here we're
just coming around talking about it
sorry dude neighbors I apologize
oh my god dude no man that wasn't even
though
oh my god dude and then he just stands
at the bottom of the stairs and just
looks longily at the door
I'm rubbing his neck like what oh no
my life is over right now I mean that is
tough
oh God I know
how is this not more viral I mean it's
making us round it's making this round
bro it is crazy I got sent this like a
good 40 times
that called this a good point yeah
that's crazy has that ever happened to
you Al a Freudian slip no yeah a Mormon
missionary we're just here trying to
spread the gospel it hasn't thankful
are you good what have you you can tell
how embarrassed like he was so
embarrassed by it yeah
yeah that's crazy trying to sell him
something and turns out yeah he lives
Three Doors Down yo you gotta see him
every day oh man that's [ __ ] rough so
the question is like does he say it I
mean
cause you told him what you I live 43
the property value oh sorry
he said what door he's in yeah
he said the address and his first name
hey I'm Fernando I live in 1843 like
literally lives in 1843.
God damn and then I'm curious the
neighbor's reaction I'm so disappointed
the neighbor just went back inside like
what like ah the neighbor said no it's
dead yeah yeah you know what I mean like
that's it like I think he handled that
[ __ ] right now all right let's get upset
like he didn't even really guess he was
clearly upset I think the grown-up ways
we're not talking there's no
conversation I'm not listening to your
apology I'm out I think that was the I
think that's the best way to handle it
because I didn't do it on purpose you
didn't knock on the door like hey I'm
selling solar panels to you know what I
mean yeah that's that's crazy
what are you really gonna do because he
can't even get no solar panel think
about that
you don't think he wants solar panels
you don't think he's gonna get free
solar panels after this [ __ ]
nah that's what he should have stayed
out there today oh how expensive are
they now yeah how much are they now dude
no that's crazy because what have he
been waiting to be asked like he goes yo
Fernando down 1843 got these solar
panels they're going to drop the energy
bill down to zero dollars
and he knocks on the door just n-words
him right there the craziest part is he
touched him afterward he's like oh I'm
sorry buddy real slip you know
the dude's reaction is crazy like the
fact that he do nothing what would you
have done like I definitely would have
got loud maybe maybe a shove maybe a
shove I can't well he's not coming at
you come on bro he's not coming at you
with anger or violence that's the thing
that's why it's like what if someone
politely calls you damn word
excuse me mister like if somebody says
yeah I'm getting loud like but why what
the [ __ ] you talking about like you get
it and then he was like I said pardon me
mister
I'm back you you hit him yeah
immediately if he doubles up so you get
loud and he apologizes then what then
what if he had a borax accent get the
[ __ ] out of here okay
that's your big your big beef with this
guy he just ate that [ __ ] he did the
same thing without saying anything bro
you know what the crazy thing about
fighting over someone calling you the
n-word is that
if you lose that fight bro
everybody call you the animals like like
there's even more pressure on the black
dude not only you gotta [ __ ] the dude up
that calls you inward no sorry not only
do you have to do something you got [ __ ]
you can't lose yeah you gotta win yeah
but he's not gonna fight back because
he's in the wrong uh that's how you know
he's not really racist yeah but this is
this is how you get a free shot he could
have got a free shot on dude dude can't
hit him back you get a free knockout
world star let's go it's a slap you
like oh yeah
yeah that's the Will Smith [ __ ] too the
guy tried to kiss him that reporter or
whatever like try to punk him like by
kissing him yeah and he just like just
like one time yeah back of the hand is
awesome yeah but this dude knocked the
guy out with it oh yeah yeah I saw that
yeah yeah that's insane the other thing
I'm curious about with this is like he
chooses to post this on the internet
what's your take on that what do you
mean
it's not a ring camera yeah so I'm
assuming he posted and goes you guys
won't believe what happened yeah this is
your payback yeah you called me the
n-word to my face I didn't beat you up
you're gonna get publicly humiliated
bare minimum now to Alex's part would
you rather get beaten up if you're
Fernando mm-hmm I would oh private
humans private humiliation humiliation
you get slapped up Alex is actually
being more Humane just beating the guy
Alex wouldn't do this son nah you right
I'm wrong
[Laughter]
let's go
private humiliation
over public every single day oh yeah and
also if you [ __ ] him up you can't even
really be that angry at him no more yeah
you have a neighbor again
yeah like it ain't even awkward just
come get beat up and then we'll have
Sunday dinners yo I'm really sorry about
that yo me too man I was a little crazy
but you did a thing you could be friends
good yeah that's the best way to make
friends with a black neighbor if you
really think about it yo if you really
think about it
[Music]
goes with your black neighbor the Casual
brush off is the fun it's the [ __ ]
craziest part he actually
like it's like he told him the wrong
name
[ __ ] mind-boggling like you don't
realize this is oh my God you got a
mortified walk off holy [ __ ] I'm so
sorry go to the end hope you don't get
[ __ ] up I can't fast forward why not
son because it's Instagram there's
literally something right there okay
that's a screen recording oh
yeah
this is insane wait are we dumb to think
that that's yeah we're not done to think
that no you guys are super smart
foreign
so we do solar around here we're just
coming around talking to [ __ ]
sorry dude neighbors I apologize man
no man that wasn't even though
um
sorry dude it's crazy
you got to give him one stiff [ __ ]
at least one stiff [ __ ]
so that's what I'm saying he had to do
something bro oh sorry dude it was so
like that is the weirdest part of it yo
let's look at the color it's like a
nervous chuckle like are you serious
yeah yeah yeah Finley then what the [ __ ]
is there any any funny comment I have a
feeling there's not bro one Off Script a
bit
bro